we are very excited that our next guest
is here today she's actress and producer
sophia bush known for her roles on you
know this show one tree hill chicago pd
and this is us
now in a new tv show it's called good
sam she plays dr sam griffin a heart
surgeon so she takes over as chief of
surgery after her boss falls into a coma
and months later he wakes up and demands
his job back
sounds interesting except gets a little
more complicated because the demanding
surgeon is also her dad here's a clip
from the season premiere which airs on
wednesday
but i vow to carry on his legacy to the
best of my ability
it's beautiful
hi oh i'm sorry
thank you
just trying to keep it tight and play to
the audience
which is oh you know boring rich donors
well at least there's an open bar
plan on hitting that hard post speech
i'm sam by the way everyone knows who
you are dr griffith ah a malcolm
kingsley
is in the
kingsley family foundation currently
underwriting the expansion of our
surgical wing
aka born rich donor
i love that the boring rich donor sophia
good to see you i love that the boring
rich donor was a person of color that
was a first for me i thought that was a
really nice touch but the clip i don't
think really does the show justice
because a lot of it is focused on the
dynamic between you and your dad which
is really fascinating the show starts
with a bang right off the bat right off
the gate really really well done but i
was reading about you that when you were
a kid you dreamed of becoming a doctor
so is this kind of a dream come true
kinda sorta
gail i'll tell you what every aspect of
our show is fabulous from the character
you just got a preview of edwin hodge
playing to jason isaacs deliciously
playing my foil
as you know my boss and father but for
me personally yes it's a dream come true
i i always actually wanted to go to med
school be a heart surgeon and then as
many artists do i
got a taste for the theater and and kind
of you hear me set fire to those dreams
and so i finally get to tell my parents
that i'm a doctor baby yes it's great
i'm very very pleased
yes very pleased and you do a great job
on the show too sophia it's really
really very well thank you well done
that's for sure now you have said that
you planned on
taking a break from network tv what
about this character this show made you
change your mind
you know i really did the last couple of
years i've been producing and developing
podcasts and you know working on
great streaming shows on hulu and
netflix you mentioned i i did go back
for this as us but who wouldn't it's
such a great wonderful family show
and
this show hit me in kind of the same way
you know one of the lovely journalists
we just spoke to who saw the first two
episodes actually called it a great
combination of this is us in succession
and i thought can those be our
billboards those are two of my favorite
shows in the world and
and i think that's what it is i think
it's the family dynamic that's both so
rooted in
love of people and in hope and helping
and also
where family can be incredibly
complicated and competitive and you get
that generational battle between these
two characters
it's everything i want to see on screen
and i feel incredibly lucky to be a part
of it
hey sophia it's tony you also host a
podcast called drama queens and you've
said that it's a way for you and your
co-host to reconnect with an earlier
show in your career one tree hill
that little show this show yeah people
love this show i i would love to hear
your thoughts on the possibilities of a
reboot but also talk about what that
reconnection with the show is like for
you
you know for us i think it's an
incredible
driving force you know it's the it's the
show that launched all of our careers we
were on it together for nine years
there's my gals um and joy and hillary
and i just thought you know as young
women coming up in the industry we
didn't have the greatest experience as
so many young women did not you know
that's that's no secret
and for us this was really about
reclaiming our show it was about taking
all of the joy and the power back and
taking out the trash
and look people have asked us about a
reboot for 10 years we've always said
never say never
i think our podcast is proof that as
three producers we have a lot of ideas
and that's kind of all i can say about
that at this point oh
yeah i like number one i like that
little smile you're giving us sophia but
i love too the never say you know how it
is
sophia you know how it is we thank you
we are cheering you on you can watch
good sam on wednesday nights at 10 9
central right here on cbs or you can
stream it on viacom cbs streaming
service paramount plus